تجهيز اكبر عدد من وجبات الافطار
للمحتاجين ليس بالامر اليسير بالنسبه
لهؤلاء فجهودهم التطوعيه تصطدم بتداعيات
الانهيار الاقتصادي في لبنان
ارتفعت اسعار لوازم الافطار من خضار ولحوم
بنسب كبيره وبرزت معادله شائكه بات التعوق
عمل اغلب الجمعيات الخيريه حجم الطلب اكثر
بكثير بكثير بكثير من الناس اللي عم تتبرع
يعني الناس اللي بتتصل فينا بدها حصص مونه
وبدها وجبات وبدها تبرعات اكثر بكثير من
الناس
واقع يستدعي تكثيف الجهود لمساعده
المحتاجين
والمتطوعون هنا يؤكدون ان التحديات لن
تخمد همتهم في عمل الخير وبيان معاني
الشهر الفضيل ومع اشتداد الازمه على
اغلبيه اللبنانيين باتت مروى امام مهام
جديده في عملها التطوعي
لتاخذ الوجبات اليوميه السخنه فهالسنه
كمان زدنا مثل كل سنه انه نحن نوصلهم هذا
الوجبات لعندهم وانا شخصيا انه قدمهم
بالموتور وصلها للناس اللي على بيوتها
يعني تقدر تاكل صحن الاكل مثل ما شفته
تفضلوا معي
هكذا اذا تضع الظروف المعيشيه المترديه في
لبنان معوقات وتفرض تحديات جمه في مسار
التكافل والتضامن الاجتماعي
عاما تلو اخر تشتد وطاط الانهيار
الاقتصادي على الصائمين في رمضان وتظهر
الارقام ارتفاع تكلفه الافطار لعائله
واحده بنسبه كبيره مقارنه بالاعوام
السابقه نتيجه التدهور المستمر لقيمه
الليره وارتفاع اسعار السلع والمواد
المختلفه وباتت المبالغ المخصصه يوميا
لافطار عائلي تعادل راتبا شهريا لموظف
حكومي
ليس هذا فحسب فثمانون في المئه من
اللبنانيين امام افق يبدو مسدودا نتيجه
تردي اوضاعهم المعيشيه صفيه واحده ممن قضت
الازمه الاقتصاديه على قدرتهم الشرائيه
خاصه في رمضان رمضان كنا عليها
مثلا صحن الفتوش الشوربه لكن الاساسيه هلا
ما في ما في شيء منه ابدا ابدا
ويزيد انقطاع التيار الكهربائي عند
الافطار من الواقع المرير هنا كان شتى
انواع المعاناه اجتمعت على مائده واحده